TO MAKE I
CONS STICK.
BATTED AWAY.
FOLLOWING UP IS
BAILEY. IN FRONT
LEE WITH A QUICKDeMELO PINCHINGO
CENTER ICE.O FIND
IT.
EHLEAL. WIDE OF THE
GOAL.
RACINGN -- SOROKIN
HAS SEEN ENOUGH AND WISELY HANGS
ON.
OUT.
IT TO
SOROKIN.
IN BY SVECHNIKOV.
THE PLAY UP THE BOARDS AND
SVECHNIKOV STANDS HIS
>> A GREAT COACH AN QUALITY
THE BLUELINE.
IT'S OFF A SKATE ACROSS.
GETSTS GAME BACK AFTER
SITTING FIVE FOR COVID. PARISE,.
THE -- IN FRONT.
THE JETS CLEAR
REACH OF STANLEY BRINGS
IT BACK TO THEISLES OVER THE LI.
BAILEY OVER
GREAT SAVE COMRIE ON THE TIP
FROM BESIDE THE GOAL BY NELSON
TRIED TO PULL IT IN FRONT BUT
IT'S TAPPEPE GAME.
>> GOOD CHANCES ON EITHER
MIDDLE AND BREAKING UP THE FIRS.
AND FEEDS IT IN FOR DILLON.
BACK TO EHLERS.
CHECKED BY
DO AGAINST -- THIS IS WHAT CIZIS
IS STOPPED BY COMRIE WHO LAYS
DOWN THE GLOVE TO HANG ON.
SOME REALLY NICE WORK BY
CLUTTERBUCK
THE START TOMORROW AND SOROKIN
WILL GET A GAME OFF HAND AND HEE
ISLANDER'S LEAD IN THE
JETS WILL LIKE THAT ONE.
BEFORE JOINING THE U.S. OLYMPIC
TEAM BACK
PALMIERI IN.
DENIED.THER END PALMIERI IS
LOOSE AND COMES TO THE MIDDLEE F
.
TWO GOOD CHANCES FOR BARZAL AND
IT'S STILL A TWO-GOAL GAME.
THREE-0 BUT THE CROSSBAR WON
THAT ONE. FRONT FOR
LEE LOOKING FOR